Pues ahí hay varios riesgos o lo que se
ve son como acosos y ataques online
cuando mujeres por ejemplo con un perfil
público
se expresan online que las respuestas Y
los ataques que reciben tienen un
carácter misógino que puede tener un
carácter como muy violento como amenazas
de violación por ejemplo amenazas de
violencia en la vida real pero que se
transforman como como
a un nivel mucho más
desarrollado de lo que se vería en la
vida real por un lado porque
los acosadores se sienten protegidos por
internet Así que como que no hay límites
en lo que se pueda hacer también la
forma por ejemplo de revelar datos
personales de las mujeres online o sea
por una forma de ataque de acoso que si
se quiere realmente dar miedo o sea
poniendo por ejemplo una dirección de
una mujer online puede llamar la
atención y puede llamar una violencia
física también para las niñas o sea las
niñas y también mujeres el problema de
pornografía de venganza por ejemplo O
sea la posibilidad de de compartir
fotos íntimas a todo el mundo no O sea y
y la posibilidad también de de crear
deefates o sea de crear fotos que
parecen ser de una mujer pero que no lo
son Realmente y esas imágenes de forma
pornográfica y creo que realmente el
problema fundamental es esa posibilidad
de compartir por todo el mundo o sea y y
la inhabilidad O sea de parar
forma en que esas imágenes o que es esas
cosas
se transforman en algo mundial